the only the only thing we can do is get
statistics and as well a lot of a lot of
the statistics that I said they're not
normally The Narrative so I don't have a
reason to skew the data if you get me of
course they do
if I do a study on oh uh what do people
like for breakfast and I want to Target
I want McDonald's to be the best answer
I will go yeah that's fine yeah that's
what I'm saying so what I'm saying is
when we're talking about now but
independent people do that so they will
okay but when we look at who owns who
owns the world's Consumer Debt but the
thing is and they can put men or women
it's you can't really you can't really
you can't you can't really f up those
stats Here Auntie you got to talk in
your mind sorry traditional Bangladeshi
women the husbands are in charge of the
money the husband deals with the money
so that they they won't be going for
credit or anything like that so when she
says oh yeah the Bangladeshi women you
know that my my mom never had a credit
card no because your husband was looking
after her that's why she never had to
have any credit and if you have all
those children he's got two wives he's
looking after the family so if there's
going to be anyone that's going to get
credit it's always going to be the men
because traditional Bangladeshi
traditional English traditional Asian
women the men are the lead of the
household they control the money so of
course her mum never went and got credit
because the husband looked after a fixer
if anybody's going to go and get credit
it'd be the husband I'll get certain
area groups that they know are the most
the rice arrived they're peer-reviewed
studies they've actually had to go for a
peer review it's not like my pro music
it's your face every time someone makes
a point look at both of their faces
reviewed and holistic studies and
they've been Ace I can't believe this
woman has a master's degree no no no no
no no no no no
I've star rated but on a scale yeah
every study has a reason why they want
to find out something yeah hypothesis
but exactly doesn't mean you're biased
towards no it's just that you find out
what the hypothesis is not avoid but you
can then modify it because for example
if you can just tell daily so much
smarter than her oh yeah and she's
what's waffling now she just keeps
saying words uh the poor parts of London
you might get McDonald's the best answer
you might go to Chelsea and you'll get
bloody girl to get what I mean but the
fact you've done statistics you know the
whole thing about statistics and
obviously I've done a lot of it from for
my job is reliability and validity the
validity does it do what it's supposed
to do reliability how often can it be
retested and get it let's get the same
answer yeah if it's a good study and
it's reliable that point you've just
mentioned is yeah
but you need to change the demographic
if you're gonna say okay sorry I am I
know you're going to watch this
you're not feminine I'm sorry nothing
about you is feminine he the guy on the
left tried to talk
remember when I said before that it
seems like it's easier to get a degree
than Common Sense she proves me right
yeah so to me you need to include my
culture and my faith
if I say women are worse with money in
general
and you get triggered that's your own
damn fault English with that how did you
know that Auntie Jenny's very good with
money she has she bought her house in
cash she's very good with money but she
doesn't get triggered because she has an
IQ of more than two I swear to God I
swear to God no because because you know
women in general aren't good with money
I'm not a big spender I'm the only woman
in my family that's good with money yeah
yeah
because the UK population six percent of
us is that little can only get so many
so either way the statistics are correct
no they're not
that's what you mean all right all right
it's all right
hold up hold up unless you unless you do
it every single person
that's the plain people is Just Landing
[Laughter]
the statistics
that suit your argument which is fine
then bring the other ones that's fine
you use a lot of Statistics we didn't
know that what duh
but listen to what I'm trying to say so
you singing like once like certain
statistics but you're not looking at the
other side so out like we had a
discussion about how
um men and women so about she was saying
that men don't actually have a lot of
sex and I was saying actually they do
because they have lots of like women
a small fractions
reality in African man not hair
statistic that she was relying on she
was saying like 30 of men have not
actually had sex however statistics
shows that men have multiple women like
double of what women have you're wrong
no no but what I'm trying to say is the
point is if you look at different types
of Statistics it's going to see your
arguments but if I say yeah men are more
likely to have multiple women that's
facts that suits my argument the whole
minority of men we're all men here
can I give you back now but we're all
men here says we know there's man in the
group that never got nothing in fact we
know that Canada's man you know when he
goes he's clearing up you know that okay
the point is the men that are having sex
they're having a lot of women the
statistics not talking about that okay
can I oh he's not talking they're
talking it's not talking about that okay
it's about looking at the biggest hit
tonight yeah and the bigger picture is
not the argument we were saying because
we're talking about baby mamas and then
she was like oh yeah not actually to be
fair they're not really having that much
sex I'm like yo but there's a lot of men
having lots of babies no the minority
now the host is trying to shut down the
show they're still over to talk in the
house and she claims number podcast
etiquette and she's still over talking
him and she doesn't even understand
statistics the minute they're talking
and telling you that this is what the
statistics say and she still wants to
argue she's got nothing to argue about
but she's arguing the men she just
expected that because she knows them and
they're her friends that they're going
to agree with her but men don't want to
look stupid they want to tell the truth
they want they don't mind you know you
want to make yourself look stupid you go
ahead 30 have not had sex that means 70
have had sex right it's double of men of
double of women are having multiple
women that's a lot of men no it's not
having them they probably just had sex
within me yeah
I like the guy they're both funny he's
funny
this is
this again
how late are you still in the air
okay
yes it isn't showing that one in uh one
in four one two three
I'm not quoting the statistics but I
just want to show you an example like
one in uh one in four Asian men get
stopped in search by the police but it's
one in two black men right that's it
it's more black men are committed no no
wait let me finish let me show you that
no no no that's not why that's not why
no no no no no
hold up wait no but they're going
through it
respond to this because how can you say
if they're singing they're more likely
to be stopped and such obviously they're
more likely to be arrested it doesn't
matter anymore
no it means that they're focusing on
them no
because I'm not gonna lie you
you won't pass a typical black man
getting stopped and such under that you
look you could pass as more Asian anyway
but let me let me land anyway now she's
saying that it looks Asian
but yeah she was saying that she that
she don't know Bangladesh you want me to
see this the next minute she's that now
she's saying that black girl looks Asian
get down the statistics further it's
more Caribbean men that are stopped at
just say one in one in two right then
African men are stopped at one in four
but that makes the system stick go
higher right Asian men Indian men and
Pakistani are hardly stopped but it's
Bengali men that are stopped at one in
four same rate as African men more
crimes no no it's not that no it's not
that it's because it's because of how we
look we look darker we could pass as
black right so when the police see us
when a racist police officer sees us
he's seeing us as you must have black in
you do you get what I mean but people
don't talk about how when if I was to
now say Asian men Bengali are suffering
the same rate as an African man people
like that's wild the statistics on
shoulder but they don't actually break
down and show that it's the Indian
that's making it look like it's one in
four Asians nobody could break that you
could break down statistics like that
with everything people could say oh
who's God
but you're gonna then undermine the
Bengali man iferation
they've been saying even the guy is not
saying we need to wind it up Eddie's
been looking but we need to get out the
studio we need to wind it up she's so
feminine she's
done getting stopped yes
but you're making men are suffering the
most you get what I mean but listen we
need to round up plug yourselves okay
we're gonna we're gonna cut
um don't shop till the end they still
don't shut up as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible